we'll return to mit's plasma science and
future Center but let us Linger on the
uh destruction of human civilization uh
which brings us to the topic of nuclear
fission what is that uh so the the
process that is inside uh nuclear
weapons and current nuclear power plants
so it relies on the same underlying
physical principle but it's exactly the
opposite of which actually the names
imply Fusion means bringing things
together fission means splitting things
apart so fission requires the heaviest
instead of the lightest and the most
unstable versus the most stable uh
elements so this tends to be uranium or
plutonium primarily uranium so take
uranium so uranium-235 is one of the
that this is one of the heaviest
unstable elements and what happens is
that this is and fission is triggered by
the fact that one of these subatomic
particles the neutron which has no
electric charge basically gets in
proximity enough to this and and
triggers an instability effectively
inside of this what is teetering on the
border of instability and basically
splits it apart
and that's the fission right the
fissioning
um and so when that happens because the
products that are and kind of roughly
splits in two but it's not even that
it's actually more complicated splits
into this whole array of lighter
elements and nuclei and when that
happens there's less rest Mass
uh uh laugh than the than the original
one so it's actually the same so it's
again it's rearrangement of the strong
nuclear force that's happening
um but that's the source of the energy
and so in the end it's like so this is a
famous graph that we show everybody is
is basically it turns out every element
that exists in the periodic table all
the things that make up everything have
uh have a remember you asked a good
question it was like so should we think
of mass as being the same as stored
energy yes so you can make a plot that
basically shows the relative amount of
stored energy in all of the elements
that are stable and make up basically
the world okay in the universe and it
turns out that this one has a maximum
amount of of stability or storage at
iron
so it's kind of in the middle of the
periodic table because this goes from
you know it's roughly that and so this
what that means is that if
um if you take something heavier than
iron like uranium which is which is more
than twice as heavy than that and you
split apart if you somehow just
magically you just split apart as
constituents and you get something
that's latter that will because it moves
to a more stable energy state it
releases kinetic energy that's the
energy that we use kinetic energy
meaning the movement of things so it's
actually an energy you can do something
with and fusion sits on the other side
of that because it's also moving towards
iron but it's do it has to do it through
Fusion together so this leads to some
pretty profound differences as I said
they have some underlying physics or
science
um uh proximity to each other but
they're literally the opposite so Fusion
why is this it actually goes into
practical implications of it which is
that fission can happen at room
temperature
it's because there's this neutron has no
electric charge and therefore it's
literally room temperature neutrons that
actually trigger the reaction so this
means
um in order to establish uh what's going
on with it and it works by a chain
reaction is that you can do this at room
temperature so Enrico Fermi did this
like on a on a University campus
University of Chicago campus the first
sustained you know chain reaction was
done underneath the squash court
with a big blocks of graphite you know
it was still don't get me wrong an
incredible human achievement right but
that's you know and then you think about
Fusion I have to build a Contraption of
some kind that's going to get to 100
million degrees okay wow that's a big
difference the other one is about the
chain reaction that namely fission works
by the fact that when that fission
occurs it actually produces free
neutrons
free neutrons particularly if they get
slow down to room temperature trigger
can trigger other fission reactions if
there's other uranium nearby or
physometer
so this means that the way that it
releases energy is that you set this up
in a very careful way such that every on
average every reaction that happens
exactly releases enough neutrons and
slows down that they actually make
another reaction one exactly one and
what this means is that because each
reaction releases a fixed amount of
energy you do this and then in time this
looks like just a constant power output
so that's how our fission power plant
works and so there's control of the the
chain reactions is extremely difficult
and extremely important for it's very
important and when you intentionally
design it that it creates more than one
fission reaction per per starting
reaction that it exponentiates away
but which is which is what a nuclear
weapon is yeah so how does an atomic
weapon work how does a hydrogen bomb
work asking for a friend yeah
yeah so um at its heart what it ha what
you do is you very quickly put together
enough of these materials that can
undergo fission with room temperature
neutrons and you put them together fast
enough that what happens is that this
process can essentially grow
mathematically like very fast and so
this releases large amounts of energy so
that's the underlying reason that it
works
so you've heard of a fusion weapon so
this is interesting is that it is it but
it's dislike Fusion Energy in the sense
that what happens is that you're using
Fusion reactions to but it's simply it
increases the gain actually of the
weapon rather than
um it's it's not a pure at its heart
it's still a fission weapon you're just
using Fusion reactions as a sort of
intermediate Catalyst basically to get
even more energy out of it
but it's not directly applicable to to
be used in an energy source does it
terrify you just again to step back at
the philosophical that humans have been
able to use physics and
uh engineering to create such powerful
weapons
I wouldn't say terrify I mean we should
be
this is the this is the progress of
human every time that we've gone access
you talk again you know the day the
universe changed those really changed
when we got access to new kinds of
energy sources but every time you get
acts and typically what this meant was
you get access to more intense energy
right that's and that's what that was
and so the ability to move from burning
wood to using coal to using gasoline and
petrol and then finally to use this is
that
is that both the potency and the
consequences are elevated
around those things it's just like you
said the
the way that Fusion nuclear fusion would
change the world
I don't think unless we think really
deeply we'll be able to anticipate some
of the things we can create there's
going to be a lot of amazing stuff but
then that amazing stuff is going to
enable more amazing stuff and more
unfortunately or uh depending how you
see on it more powerful weapons well
yeah but see that's the thing Fusion
breaks that Trend in the following way
so one of them so Fusion doesn't work on
a chain reaction
there's no Chain Reaction zero so this
means it cannot physically exponentiate
away on you because it works and
actually this is why Star by the way we
know this already it's why stars are so
stable why most stars and suns are so
stable it's because they are regulated
through their own temperature and their
Heating
because what's happening is not that
there's some probability of this
exponentiating away is that the energy
that's being released by Fusion
basically is keeping the fire hot
and these tend to be you know and when
it comes down to thermodynamics and
things like this there's a reason for
example it's pretty easy to keep of
constant temperature like in an oven and
things like this it's the same thing
infusion so this is actually one of the
features that I would argue Fusion
breaks the breaks the trend of this is
that it's it has more energy intensity
than than fission on on paper but it
actually does not have the consequences
of control and sort of Rapid Release of
the energy because it's actually it the
physical system just doesn't want to do
that yeah we're gonna have to look
elsewhere for the weapons with which we
fight World War III
fair enough